buchstaben begegnen uns im alltag
überall meist mit konkrete bedeutung
aber nicht immer das geschäft itb in
berlin verkauft ausschließlich produkte
auf die einzelne buchstaben gedruckt
sind plakate postkarten
bücher und sogar lebensmittel gibt es
hier
jochen rädeker und kirsten dietz die
gemeinsam ein designbüro führen haben
den laden 2013 eröffnet gestaltung ist
was mich immer begeistert hat buchstaben
sind was in der gestaltung oft so im
hintergrund steht was man gar nicht
wahrnimmt
gleichzeitig lesen wir milliarden davon
in unserem leben und die schöner zu
machen ist einfach etwas gewesen was
mich persönlich fasziniert hat sie dann
auf schöne produkte zu bringen weil die
ideen diesen daten und entstanden ist
was was einfach spaß macht eine noch
funktionierende druckerpresse und alte
blei setzkästen erinnern an eine
historische drucker werkstatt aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert
im laden gibt es außerdem eine milchbar
und das hat einen bestimmten grund
wir wollten einen laden mit buchstaben
auf machen ihm gleich satz was früher so
dass das blei in der luft giftig war und
calcium bindet diese giftstoffe also
haben die lehrlinge früher milch
bekommen von ihrem lehrmeister und da
lag es nahe hier auf eine milchbar
reinzumachen nun tritt man nicht
unbedingt milch pur gibt es hier zwar
auch aber im kaffee schmeckt ja auch
nicht schlecht
deswegen laden plus kaffee auch künstler
haben buchstaben als element ihrer kunst
entdecken so der spanier jaume plensa er
baut gigantische objekt aussehen
in seinen werken stecken botschaften die
von träumen und poesie handeln sich aber
auch auf gesellschaftliche entwicklungen
beziehen
der deutsche künstler der cracker
zeichnet bilder mit den buchstaben
seiner schreibmaschine seine motive
entstehen durch wiederholtes tippen von
wörtern sätzen und buchstaben über neben
und hintereinander
reiter räumte diese werke
die britin keira rathbone erschafft
ebenfalls bilder mit hilfe einer
schreibmaschine ihre porträts erscheinen
auf den covern von büchern und
zeitschriften und kosten bis zu 6000
euro tattoos sind schriften gefragt
prominente wie angelina jolie schmücken
sich mit asiatischen zeichen
david beckham seine ehefrau victoria und
pop stahl nicki minaj tragen lettern auf
der haut
in berlin gibt es das weltweit einzige
buchstaben museum
mehr als 800 buchstaben lager sie
zierten einst schaufenster und fassaden
oder stammen von privaten sammlern
die exponate sollen das bewusstsein der
öffentlichkeit für typografie wecken
barbara die hand gründete das museum vor
zehn jahren aus leidenschaft
man kann da wirklich ganz
unterschiedliche gefühle und interessen
hervorlocken bei den besuchern so manche
erkennen darin eben von früher
da fallen dann persönliche geschichten
ein manche sind ganz fasziniert endlich
mal vor so einem drei meter großen
buchstaben zu sehen und wir haben
festgestellt dass jeder buchstabe ihm
sein eigenes leben hatte weil wir
übernehmen ja immer gebraucht im
buchstaben aus dem öffentlichen raum
meistens da an sind die
hintergrundgeschichten natürlich super
interessant
zurück im berliner concept store von
kirsten dietz von jochen rädeker
auf der website ihres ladens kann sich
jeder sein persönliches lieblingswort
zusammenstellen
mit buchstaben spielen ist einfach was
wir seit kindheit an gerne gemacht haben
beim lesenlernen und jetzt vielleicht
auch wenn man schon lesen kann beim
produkte zusammenstellen